[Music]
someone's moaning up a storm out there
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to spooky cellar all right
you can shut up now any second now so
this is probably the scariest okay what
does that even mean why's the walk okay
alright I'll walk I didn't know this was
a little early the game no time to
explain
oh it is okay is that a flashlight oh it
is space to jump you're just gonna throw
me right into it now this might be this
scariest game you ever see today so
buckle up turn up your volume and your
headphones turn out the light and get
ready to have the pants spook tough yeah
because it's about to get dank and it's
about to get dark and it's about to get
spooky why do I need to sprint wow I
need to sprint what is that nothing
absolutely dick diddly oh hey
even down darker deeper Oh for one I
don't like that at oh okay no hope
yeah no joke okay alright well
whatever's down here it's not gonna be a
match for me so I might as well give up
go [ __ ] itself and get out of my face
before I even get close to it hi what
did I just see oh hi okay alright that's
not okay that's not okay hey hey what
are you doing over there
what was that why am i down here with it
why did I need to come down into the
cellar when I was perfectly fine
upstairs I know is this another way down
oh I think I'm winning not hot I wasn't
sure but I think I'm winning okay what
did I pick up
Oh picked up keys so that I could open
that I know that slinky sounded keys so
he's just not gonna explain whatever the
hell was glowing in the darkness over
there whose two burning eyeballs there's
giant luminescent body and it's rather
pungent odor you weren't gonna say
anything about that am I supposed to be
looking for something am I supposed to
be finding something is it something in
the documents that I need and if you
know tell me right now before I punch
you in the dick anybody if you even have
a dick your big round body didn't
suggest anything to the biggest nature
Tom and I assume that to know and I'm
gonna carry on my way I can't get a
bearing on where I am because it's just
a bunch of convoluted hallways with no
end if I know my thing about cars that's
the new predicament that I have to deal
with and I can't sprint very far because
I'm out of shape I ate too many
doughnuts over at Kay okay all right you
can stop huffing and puffing in my ear
it's not gonna do any good
I cannot spray no pike it was like it
was like it was like a basement or
something it's like a spooky cellar this
all leads into nothing it's a whole lot
of nothing if I didn't know any better
I'd say that I'm running in circles
well found my way back to the beginning
of the battle that is good for me at
least now I know that I'm making
absolutely no progress so I should just
bend over and kiss my ass good-bye oh I
need a key
that is obvious to me oh happy day
so I got to find a key is probably in
somewhere that I've been before but I
didn't see it because I didn't know that
I was looking for what that was that
that we're virgins is gonna be like that
then I'm just gonna say hey wait a
minute wait I've solved the conundrum I
seem to be on the other side of the
fence now I guess that means I'm doing
just okay nothing nothing gonna be
bothering me no how no way oh you guys
you guys being bothered at all no way no
how
so obviously this game wasn't supposed
to take itself too terribly seriously
it's kind of a ridiculous concept it's
kind of silly because the enemies aren't
exactly the most threatening of sorts
but at least grandpa was nice to me
upstairs I don't know why shoved me in
this dark dank cellar filled with
monsters hey I can always assume that
he's looking out for the best
[Music]
well if that's how you're gonna be huh
okay all right oh I don't know if you're
randomly generated or if I have to find
a very specific exit oh wow my friend
okay let's not use it it's not bad since
I can't go I'm crapping my pants okay
well hey I thought you changed your mind
at least I explode blood all over the
screen who Weishaupt the pot ascend of
something that didn't like and that is a
very rare occurrence yeah I thought it
was gonna be a dead end we got away from
it oh my god okay all right then if
you're just gonna do that to me then I'm
just gonna point you in the dick if you
even have a dick oh it's right by me
isn't it okay maybe not mmm all right
we're fine I mean we're not fine because
they can't find the frickin way out of
here
at least I'm fine I feel fine I look
fine
damn I am fine oh jeez what kind of
t-rex ass roar was that for attitude
over there yeah you ever just have a bad
feeling crawling down your spine as if
you know some horrible monstrosity
lurking around every corner
whoa never mind
those were the pleasant tingles of
success I thought I was gonna die Oh
grab on grab on grab on oh no I don't
want the good
[Music]
that's how we're gonna be then I see
damn it why why bright up Oh unfuck this
seems to be uh Perdue way out maybe I
couldn't fly my flip maybe I didn't talk
out my ass francs oh you better not come
around this corner I'm naked you
wouldn't want to see anything about that
right so I just got to find my way out
of here I just got to keep an eye out
for the cellar door when we find the
cellar door is that grandma oh I have a
feeling that is grandma grandma Millie
oh oh it's not it's a comforting barrel
of fire maybe I can throw myself in it
so I wouldn't have to subject myself to
anything that's happening over here
please grandma no grandma no no no no
what if I told you about the nice lip
[Music]
how did I survive oh I've made it great
I am so good what the [ __ ] I didn't
think that this game was actually gonna
be scary
he's the way who's advertising itself
just made it seem like it was just
ridiculous horror game and I was gonna
play it and be like yeah look how stupid
it is
jeez didn't know I'd be screaming for my
life all the time
yeah well whatever best to get my scream
box a good exercise every once in a
while can't see nothing grab up oh
grandma hey whoa whoa very stuck grandma
okay right goodbye no I know I know oh
stop stop grandma grandma that's enough
grandma your animalistic sense of dread
it's just not welcome here [ __ ] hell
oh my god my voice ah I am very much
puberty okay alright I think I'm gonna
now in there so that is that is a spooky
cellar the spooky cellar is ridiculous
but scary so if you want to check it out
for yourself a provide a link in the
description thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments below and
if you have other horror games that you
want me to play let me know them as well
thank you everybody for watching and as
always see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]